This brave scuba diver is recording sailfish
hunting a school of sardines
In order to capture such a scene,
researchers spent days on a boat
following frigate birds to the fray
In groups as small as 4 or as large as 70
the fish take turns slashing or poking
the sardine school with their toothy bills
After an attack, one fish will take a break
while another takes a shot
The researchers learned from these recordings
that only 24 percent of attacks
ended in a sardine snack
but 95 percent ended up with an injury
to a member of the sardine school
Injured sardines quickly tire,
putting them more at risk of getting snapped up
by one of the sailfish crowd
It turns out this is a simplistic but efficient
form of group hunting.
Individuals do not assume specific roles in the hunt--
--something seen in more social hunters
like chimpanzees
And the fish aren't really taking turns --
--though the attacks are well-timed,
they likely aren’t coordinated.
That might seem odd in light of these recordings,
but when one is facing a targeted swipe from a sailfish,
you’d likely get out of the way too.
[diver exclaims]